so I've been creating a brand new game
for the Sega Megadrive I'm using
original development hardware from the
90s I'm also running a small set of
tutorials onto how I got it running in
the first place today we're going to
turn the screen red but that's easier
said than done so bear with me there's a
lot to explain ok so last time we showed
the 68000 CPU with his logic cord its
registers how to add two numbers
together I had to get some basic physics
working we sure that was connected to
the bus and the bus contains ROM RAM and
aiya port a GPU maybe some other things
the bus of the collection of physical
wires that the CPU uses to talk to other
pieces of hardware
we're interested in the GPU today we're
going to initialize this thing and try
and get something on screen it's easier
said than done because we don't have any
graphics libraries on a system like this
so things like OpenGL DirectX were
non-existent back here so we have to do
everything ourselves we have to talk to
the GPU directly from the CPU so the GPU
is a processor in itself so it's a bit
like the 68000 it has its own logic core
and it has its own set of registers
these aren't general-purpose registers
for adding numbers and stuff each one
has a specific purpose so one will be in
control off the background-color one
will show where in the memory map it's
supposed to pick up certain things they
all have very bespoke purposes the GPU
has its own bus and it has its own
memory which we call VRAM and all that
is contained within this GPU here and
that poses a problem because it's on the
bus itself so we don't have direct
access to the video memory we don't have
direct access to the registers here we
have to go along the bus that the 68000
has access to so in order to do that
this processor has two ports visible to
the bus called the control port and the
data port so we can talk to these two
ports on the bus they have an address
each so we can tell the control port to
start receiving data and then we can
shove data through the data port I'm
going to show how to code that now this
is 68000 assembly language very to the
metal stuff so the first thing we need
to do is initialize the GPU we don't get
any help doing this
the Megadrive doesn't have an operating
system it doesn't have any drivers when
it's switched on it's in an
uninitialized States so it's memory by
be full of garbage its registers might
be uninitialized we don't know as we
have to do the whole thing from scratch
and the first step is to initialize each
of the registers the VDP has 24
registers and they all have specific use
cases so one will turn on the screen one
will enable DMA mode some of them set
various addresses around its memory map
some turn sprites on and off the one
we're going to be interested in today is
registered number seven which sets the
background color but we need to
initialize them all anyway the first
thing we need to do is set that up okay
so we got this load registers routine
here and that loads the address of the
register table though just showed is
going to set up a loop counter for all
24 of these registers and then one at a
time it's going to copy the data from
the table into the VDP control port here
which is the address of the GPU on the
bus and then it's going to loop around
it's going to initialize all 24 of those
so we've got that set up to call that
routine right at the top here so that's
the first we're going to do the next
stage is to clear V run because the
memory might be full of absolutely
anything possibly what was last on the
screen we lost turned on plus some
interference we don't know so I'm going
to do that manually here I've got a
macro setup to set up the V DP control
port so you can tell which address
you're about to write to that's quite a
complicated process the command you give
it needs to be in a specific bit formats
and so does the address I used to work
all these out on paper but it's just a
complete faff so I've set up a macro to
do this so we're going to do it this way
instead so we're going to use that to
clear the memory of the GPU because
that's not done for us so we're going to
set up a loop to clear the GPUs memory
it's got 64 kilobytes of RAM but we're
going to write one word at a time so we
need to write half of that so we start
by setting up a loop counter of 64
kilobytes divided by 2 and then minus 1
because that's how the loop count
put that in d0 we're going to start
writing to address zero so we're going
to use our macro set vram right now
we're going to give it the address zero
we're going to set up a hoop label here
so we're going to call this vram right
loop so in here all we're going to do is
move word size zero into the VD piece
data port and then we'll go decrement
and branch our counter which is in B
zero back up to vram write them so this
is going to start writing 64 kilobytes
worth of words into vram address zero
and it's going to loop until that's all
done and it's going to write zero into
the data port and that should clear all
the memory of the GPU so let's build
that and test that out so when we see
this just to remind me and the viewers
will see it on the right hand screen
because it will go to this advocate
which yeah yeah in the box that well
you'll see nothing because we're
clearing the memory so no nothing should
happen hopefully nothing should happen
here was this lame but I should build
okay so that's built the ROM let's fire
it up on the dev kit so this is a sega
mega-cd development kit running through
an ms-dos debugger here and we're gonna
load up the ROM that we just built and
show each of those lines in turn running
so we have the wrong boring bit boring
before and that cut the south cut this
out for this out you know source window
okay so the roms loaded on the dev kit
now the debug is ready to go so I'm
gonna hit a breakpoint here I started
running the first thing we to do is
what's called the TMS s signature the
Megadrive had a built-in security system
so that third parties couldn't write
games for the thing but it's very very
circumvent you just write a string Sager
it's a particular dress on the bus and
it lets you in and that was more a legal
challenge rather than a technic
so we can step over that that should
sort that out and then we're going to
load each of the VDP registers and turn
so if we step in here we're going to
load the address of the registers table
that I showed earlier into address
register a zero we're going to move 24
minus 1 into registered easier we're
going to use that for our loop counter
to loop over each register how we're
going to move the command 8 which
according to the GPU is to set a
register in to d1 and then we're going
to one at a time
fetch the initial register value from a0
which is our table and we're going to
add it to the command in d1 at the
moment the lower word of d1 is eight
zero zero zero so if we load the
register from the table that's going to
be eight zero one four which is going to
be set register number zero value 1 4
and then we're going to loop
continuously for all of those once we
finished looping through all of those
the GPU will be initialized so if I let
that run now and now we get something on
the screen the reason we got something
on screens because we haven't yet
cleared the memory so what's showing is
either the last thing was on screen when
the machine was last turned on or
interference or a mixture of both so the
next thing we need to do is run through
our loop here to clear all the video
memory so as as I've explained before
we're going to move 64 kilobytes worth
of words which is why it's 64 divided by
2 minus 1 for the loop counter into d0
we're going to call our macro which is
going to shuffle that address bit
pattern for us the right to vram address
0 so we're going to start from the top
of memory and then one word at a time
we're going to write 0 into the vdps
data port and that's going to write all
across memory zeros so if I let that run
we should send then see the screen
cleared because the graphics memory is
now empty ok so as you saw there the
screen was blue and not black and that's
because although we've cleared the
graphics memory we haven't yet cleared
all the palettes so the palette is
probably blue from whatever was last
going on with this machine
Sega Bluth Sega blue yes so instead
we'll define our own palette
though that it's tough for us to find a
pallet here when we call it pallet the
Megadrive has four pallets with 16
colors each and each pallet chantry is
nine bits so it's three bits cur
component three bits red three bits blue
three bits green and this means the
least significant bit of that pallet
entry is unread so for black we would
define the power to zero zero zero zero
that's an unused entry and then red
green blue for white it would be all
ease because of the least significant
bit of things so if we do 0 EEE
that's an unused entry and then eee is
red green and blue all up maximum so for
the rest of the colors for all 16 we'll
just fill them in let's have let's have
a red
let's have a green let's have a blue
it's because it's three bits for each
component not four we have one bit
discarded that's unused so the maximum
value each component of color can hold
is eat rather than F so we've got a
black a white a red a green a blue and
I've left the other colors blank so
we've got 16 colours and a pallet here
ready to go so we need to upload this to
the GPU again we've got another macro
here which is the same as the set V Ram
right macro but instead of calling the
vram right command is calling the sear
and writes command C Ram for color um
which is where the pallets are stored
so let's upload our pallet it's a
similar operation to how we cleared the
GPU we're going to set up a loop counter
there are 16 colors in the palette but -
one for the loop that's how loops work
into d0 I mean the set C Ram right zerah
zerah zerah there
so that's address error of the color
Aram in the GPU which is where the first
pallet is stored so we're going to load
the address of our pallet ready to write
so load effective address pallets and we
shove that into address register a 0 and
I'm going to set up a loop to do this so
we're going to call it C Ram right then
so for each iteration of the loop we're
going to move a word of data from a 0
and after every read from a-z
we're gonna increment the address so the
next time we come back is going to
advance the address I will move that
into VDP data and then we're gonna
decrement and branch our counter which
is d0 and loop back up to serum right
loop so let's build that run it in turn
okay so the roms loaded again we got the
debugger fired up for some reason the
pallet in memory is now white but it's
not initialized we don't know what color
is going to be so let's run through this
then we're gonna move our counter
fifteen colors - wanted to do zero we're
gonna start writing to color am address
zero using our macro we're going to load
our pallet into address a zero and then
for every entry and the pallets we're
going to write it into V DP data if I
set up running we should now finally
have a blank screen and there we go so
the V DP is now initializes memories
clear as palettes are clear we're now
ready to set the background color so
there's a lot of back-and-forth here
isn't it between various different
programs areas okay so the next thing to
do is to set the background color we're
going to do this by setting one of these
VDP registers manually
it's register seven that we're
interested in which we've initialized to
zero so at the moment the background
color is going to be palette zero color
zero or whatever's in memory at the
moment so we're going to set this
manually and to do that we're going to
use the same trick as we did to load the
initial table to start so we're going to
use command eight and then set the
register number and then set the
register value so we can do that with a
single line of code so all we need to do
to set the background color is to move
word size and we're going to use command
eight which means set register seven is
the register that we're going to write
to that's where the background color
stored we're going to use palette 0
which is the first palette of memory and
color 2 which should be our red in the
palette and we're going to write that
directly to the bdp control port there's
nothing else that needs to be done so
let's build that and run that
okay so there are now loaded I've got a
couple of great printer set so let's run
through at all first going to initialize
the VDP now that's containing whatever
garbage was on-screen last time plus
some interference and we're going to
clear the vram which clears everything
except the pallets we're going to load
our pallet which is set it black and
then finally we're going to set register
seven to pallet zero color to which
fingers cross should be read and there
you have it once you've got the basics
nailed down you've got everything into
macros and routines you can just pull it
together like Lego bricks and start
making actually games with this stuff so
I wouldn't sit and calculate these
addresses manual each time nor would I
set these VDP registers manually I'd
have my own routines written for them so
once the hard works done the hard works
done we're going to set register seven
to palate zero color three and fingers
cross this should be red okay well
they're done did you count from zero
will one kind of London do yeah 0 1 2 so
that's red green blue if I just debugged
it you did